das war es dann also mit der
maskenpflicht im Flugzeug sie soll wohl
ab Herbst aus dem Infektionsschutzgesetz
gestrichen werden aber eine Hintertür
die gibt's sobald die corona-fallzahlen
wieder hochgehen soll
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach die Möglichkeit haben den
maskenzwang wieder schnell einzuführen
ffp2-maskenpflicht im Flieger also es
war ja eh ein deutscher Alleingang und
er sorgte für große Aufregung weil kurz
vor der Entscheidung der Bundesregierung
ging ja diese Bilder hier viral die
verteilten sich im Internet die
Regierung auf dem Flug nach Kanada und
Sie sehen es hier Robert Habeck ohne
Maske unter anderem auch locker und frei
aber jetzt halt die Rolle rückwärts die
maskenpflicht im Flugzeug kommt weg
nun also doch bye bye maskenpflicht in
Flugzeugen soll es in Zukunft jetzt doch
oben ohne gehen soll aus dem
Infektionsschutzgesetz gestrichen werden
einfach so zuletzt hatte die
Bundesregierung doch noch andere Pläne
verfolgt den Plan bekannt gegeben die
maskenregeln für die Bürger sogar zu
verschärfen statt op-masken sollte eine
ffp2-maskenpflicht in Flugzeugen und dem
Fernverkehr gelten dabei hatten diese
Bilder erst für Aufruhr gesorgt denn im
regierungspfleger gelten ja sowieso
andere maskenregeln nämlich keine für
Bürger heißt es mund-nasenschutz im
politikerflieger jedoch nicht die
Doppelmoral der maskenpflicht
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
begründet das so es ist ebenso die
Lufthansa wehrte sich gegen den Plan
machte sich für eine Abschaffung der
maskenpflicht im Luftverkehr stark und
jetzt die Kehrtwende der Ampel
Bundesverkehrsminister Volker Wissing
setzt sich ein für Ende der
maskenpflicht im Flugzeug wünscht sich
ein einheitliches internationales
Vorgehen im Flugverkehr das ist eine
sehr vernünftige Entscheidung so wir
sind zu Bild tja das hat Bild schon
immer so gesehen komisch jedoch im
öffentlichen Personennahverkehr und den
Zügen gilt die maskenpflicht weiter es
ist ebenso
[Applaus]
demnächst also wieder oben ohne im
Flieger
[Musik]